[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Freitagabend ihnen allen die Welt
zwischen moralischem Anspruch und realer
Politik ein Tag heute wie ein Spagat
Händeschütteln mit einem der das Blut
seiner Landsleute an selbigen hat
Syriens Diktator ist zurück auf der
diplomatischen Bühne der arabischen Welt
außerdem neue Sanktionen des Westens
gegen Russland und gleichzeitig die
Einsicht dass die bisherigen viele
Schlupflöcher bieten weil manche Staaten
gar nicht daran denken sie zu befolgen
zwei große Gipfeltreffen heute die
Arabische Liga tagt in Jitter die
westlichen Staaten in Hiroshima viel
Symbolik bei beiden und ein gipfelgast
dessen Überraschungsbesuch heute die
beiden treffen verbindet der ukrainische
Präsident auf seiner bisher mit Abstand
weitesten Auslandsreise aus ZDF via
Saudi-Arabien nach Japan wir beginnen
unsere Berichterstattung heute Abend mit
ultra in Hiroshima
wer die Machtfrage auf dem Gipfel stellt
der hat noch nicht das japanische
Protokoll erlebt es regiert mit klaren
Ansagen nächster die Regierungschefs im
Schichtdienst für den Frieden und gute
Bilder
bitte in die Hauptkamera schauen sie
sind keine Anweisung gewohnt aber sie
spielen artig mit das Bild wird um die
Welt gehen auch viele Autokraten werden
es sich anschauen als stark und
geschlossen will die G7 wirken
die Welt ist kompliziert sagt Japans
Regierungschef kishida und zählt zur
Begrüßung die Krisen auf Klima und der
Angriffskrieg Russlands die G7 wir
müssen führen
aber wie mächtig sind die mächtigen
kishida musste erst einmal auf den
US-Präsident warten
protokollarisch eine Ewigkeit und wohl
nicht so geplant der mächtigste Mann der
freien Welt wirkt angeschlagen ein über
80-jähriger auf dem die Hoffnung der G7
der französische Präsident macron
verliert zu Hause immer mehr an
Unterstützung und der deutsche
Bundeskanzler soll mehr führen auf der
Weltbühne und daheim was
zusammenschweißt der Konsens Russland in
die Schranken zu weisen er ist auch
wichtig weil er ja auch eine Botschaft
enthält nämlich das ein fairer Frieden
nur möglich ist in Russland einsieht
dass es diesen Krieg beenden muss und
Truppen zurückziehen muss
es gab noch einen anderen Gipfel den der
anderen Seite der Weltordnung
Chinas Präsident Chi hat die
zentralasiatischen Staaten eingeladen
auch sie pflanzen Bäume der Termin wurde
auch ein Finger zeigt schieß an die G7
seht ich bin nicht allein
der Showdown der Systeme er hat schon
einmal die Welt an den Abgrund geführt
die G7 gedenken der Opfer des
atombombenabwurfes in Hiroshima
zusammenstehen gegen China und Russland
deshalb wollen die G7 Staaten weitere
Sanktionen gegen Moskau verhängen sie
könnten auch China das Russland
unterstützt damit treffen die Europäer
wissen wie gefährlich es ist sich mit
dem wirtschaftsriesen China anzulegen
das europäische Sanktionspaket wird noch
gesondert und zwar im Rahmen der
Europäischen Union verhandelt und auch
da geht es im Wesentlichen darum ganz
konkrete Präzisierung vorzunehmen die
umgebungsgeschäfte auch schwieriger
machen der izukushima schreien ein
idealer Ort den ersten Gipfeltag
ausklingen zu lassen
bitte winken lautet die Ansage des
Protokolls sie winken und sie hoffen
dass vielen der Welt zurückwinken
und am Roten Meer in der saudischen
Hafenstadt rollt die arabische Welt eine
mutmaßlichen Kriegsverbrecher den
willkommens-teppich aus
das ist die furchtbare Bilanz der
Herrschaft von Syriens Diktator Baschar
alasat der die Protestbewegung in seinem
Land brutal niedergeschlagen hat mehr
als 300.000 Tote im syrischen
Bürgerkrieg Giftgas gegen Frauen und
Kinder mehr als die Hälfte seiner
Bevölkerung vertrieben oder geflohen
trotz allem konnte sich Assad an der
Macht halten vor allem dank massiver
Hilfe aus Moskau und er darf heute
wieder Hände schütteln mit den Nachbarn
es ist wie eine Forscherin sagt der
letzte Sargnagel für den arabischen
Frühling
selbstbewusst kommt er an keinen Deut
unsicher ein strahlender Bacher al Assad
betritt die Weltbühne nur in Iran und
Russland war er bislang willkommen doch
der saudische Kronprinz bin Salman will
ihn nun wie er sagt zurück in die
Normalität der arabischen Heimat bringen
wir werden nicht zulassen dass die
Region zum konfliktiert wird deshalb
müssen wir ein neues Kapitel aufschlagen
und diese schmerzvollen Jahre der
Konflikte zurücklassen in denen die
Menschen litten und die Entwicklung der
Region stoppte
Nordsyrien im oppositionsgebiet Haus an
alhabali die hierher flüchtete vor dem
Assad Regime kann kein neues Kapitel
aufschlagen sie hat Todesangst sie
überlebte Folter und Elektroschocks ihr
Bruder verschwand in Assads Gefängnissen
durch ein herausgeschmuggeltes
gefängnisfoto erkannte sie Jahre später
seine Leiche
wenn das Regime hierherkommt wird es ein
Massaker geben wie kann es sein dass
dieses Regime nicht zur Rechenschaft
gezogen wird das ist normalisiert wird
in den Hinterzimmern wurde ein
sorbisch-syrische Deal verhandelt
arabisches Geld für Wiederaufbau im
Umtausch für die Rückkehr der
Flüchtlinge mit Assads Vorgeschichte
erscheint es nahezu utopisch aber
Saudi-Arabien verkauft diesen Weg als
alternativlos sagt ein dem Herrscherhaus
verbundene Experte
man kann nicht einfach weiter Syrien
sanktionieren und dann Syrien weiter
zerfallen sehen es ist ein 20 Millionen
Volk man kann damit nicht nur emotional
umgehen man muss jetzt praktisch stellen
er soll Assad nicht die Hände
geschüttelt haben der Präsident der
Ukraine erstmals in einer Region die
eher Russland zugeneigt ist und selbst
auf Drängen des Westens vermieten hat
klar Stellung zu beziehen angesichts der
russischen Invasion selensky weiß
saudi-Arabien hat einen engen Draht zu
Moskau der Gastgeber will vermitteln
selensky will für seinen zehn Punkte
Friedensplan werden und seine Gegner im
Saal überzeugen
leider wollen einige in der Welt und
einige hier im Saal Russlands
Gefängnisse und illegale Annexionen
nicht sehen ich bin hier damit sie die
Dinge klar sehen wie sehr auch immer
russland versucht hier zu beeinflussen
Sky und asset in einen Gipfel zu packen
ein geschickter Schachzug Saudi-Arabiens
des hiermit globale Ambitionen anmeldet
da läuft der Gipfel der Arabischen Liga
also offensichtlich ab nach dem alten
Motto des ehemaligen US-Präsidenten
Linden B Johnson ich zitiere ihn
wörtlich besser der Feind pisst aus dem
Zelt hinaus als ins Zelt hinein
bringen wir unsere Korrespondenten jetzt
mit dazu heute abend collinea Thai ist
in Kairo guten Abend das mag die
Strategie jetzt sein der arabischen Welt
aber wie muss dieses Bild von Assad
heute im trauten Kreis bei denen
ankommen die unter seiner Herrschaft
litten und leiden hat Assad jetzt
endgültig gewonnen
ja also als Opfer fragen sich warum
jemand wieder auf die Idee kommen konnte
den Bock zum Gärtner zu machen und sie
weisen darauf hin dass Assad in den all
den letzten Jahren es geschafft hat
diese Region massiv zu destabilisieren
indem er Fluchtbewegungen ausgelöst hat
indem er is-terroristen zum eigenen
Zwecke instrumentalisiert hat und indem
er Drogen produziert hat das weiß bei
uns kaum einer aber die Amphetamine die
in Syrien produziert werden das ist
assarts Lebensader das ist seine
wirtschaftsader und diese Drogen diese
Amphetamine die überfluten die ganze
Region hier also schafft Probleme und
lässt andere sie lösen und als Opfer
fragen sich wieso er eigentlich mit
dieser erpressungspolitik nach einem
jahrzehn durchgekommen ist das sei eine
sehr gefährliche Entwicklung und sie
Weise vor allen Dingen auf das Fehlen
einer internationalen syrienstrategie
hin vor allen Dingen bei den USA
man macht den der Feuer gelegt hat zum
Feuerwehrmann goldene vielen Dank für
den Moment ultra gehen wir weiter nach
Japan beim G7 Gipfel da hielt ja die
Welt früher den Atem an das ist die
geballte Macht die da zusammen sitzt
heute berichten wir gleich über mehrere
Gipfel zeitgleich ist das auch so ein
Zeichen ihr da im Westen ihr könnt nicht
mehr alleine entscheiden
ja ich glaube eindeutig ich glaube auch
dass das die G7 Staaten wissen dass die
Zeiten sich verändert haben dass die
Welt der komplizierter geworden ist und
das eben nicht mehr die G7 Staaten
alleine den Rhythmus der Welt bestimmen
das kann man alleine daran erkennen wenn
in der UNO Vollversammlung über
Russlands Angriffskrieg entschieden wird
und Russland auf die Anklagebank gesetzt
wird dann enthalten sich regelmäßig oder
wie gesagt Stimmen dagegen 47 Länder das
klingt erst nicht so viel aber das ist
etwa die Hälfte der Menschheit und da
sieht man eben wie hoch die Macht oder
die geringen die Macht der G7 Staaten
sind alles hängt glaube ich mit dem doch
langsam macht Verlust Amerikas zusammen
das ist der andere Gegenspieler China
schaut eben auf Amerika und sieht ein
zerstrittenes Land sieht einen alten
Präsidenten und einen sehr aggressiven
wahrscheinlichen gegen Kandidaten Donald
Trump und die Chinesen rechten damit
dass die amerikanische Demokratie auf
die lange Sicht immer schwächer wird und
wenn Amerika schwächer wird weil der
gegen sieben Staaten schwächer und der
Westen und dann singt auch der Einfluss
oder die werden in einem Film gerade
schon gesehen der Überraschungsgast
heute bei den arabischen Potentaten wo
wurde mir selenski aus der Ukraine das
sind ja alles Potentaten die gute trete
nach Moskau haben was will sie Lenski
dort
ja so das war eine Premiere selinski ist
heute das hat einen guten Eindruck
hinterlassen und das hat bei vielen
wirklich Sympathien geweckt das war vor
allen Dingen klug vom ukrainischen
Präsidenten auf das Schicksal der Krim
Tataren hinzuweisen auf das Schicksal
der ukrainischen Muslime und damit hat
er Türen geöffnet und das hat man ganz
deutlich gemerkt bei den Begegnungen
nach der Rede selensky erkennt die
gewachsene Rolle Saudi-Arabiens an es
erkennt die diplomatische Führerschaft
Saudi-Arabiens an und das weiß ganz
genau da sitzt einer der hat gehört in
Russland und saudi-Arabien hat schon
einmal einen Gefangenenaustausch
initiiert selenski braucht so viele
Staaten wie möglich in Gitter um für
seine zehn Punkte Friedensplan zu werden
und für eine weitere Runde der
Gefangenen Freilassung und dann Ulf
liegt selenski ja weitergehen Osten und
trifft dann in Japan beim G7 Gipfel
neben beiden und den Europäern auch auf
die die bislang dezidiert eben nicht auf
seiner Seite stehen
ja das wird ein interessanter Auftritt
von selensky es ist quasi ein Wechselbad
der Gefühle für ihn wird einmal doch
eine große Rückendeckung bekommen von
den G7 Staaten und der wird
wahrscheinlich auch etwas bekommen was
ihm sehr wichtig ist nämlich dass die
Amerikaner nicht mehr ganz so
entschieden gegen die Lieferung von
kampfstätten sind zumindestens heißt es
aus dem pressumfeld des Präsidenten
beiden dass man bereit sein an die
Trainings der Piloten wirklich
teilzunehmen und auf der anderen Seite
wird zuletzt geben auf Länder treffen
wie Indien und auch Brasilien Länder die
eben bei diesen Krieg sagen sie sind
neutral das eine europäischer Krieg der
geht es überhaupt nichts an und die
wahrscheinlich auch dass Sanktionssystem
gegen Russland unterwandern und diese
beiden treffen also einmal mit den G7
Ländern und dann eben mit den Skeptikern
zeigt die ganze Bandbreite dieses
Problems es wird also ein Gipfel am
Sonntag sein mit selenski wo man ihn
Polizei mal militärisch aufrüstet und
versucht politisch Gespräch zu führen
aber wahrscheinlich wieder keine Lösung
findet
wir werden berichten herzlichen Dank für
diese Analyse heute abend Collie und Ulf
und damit jetzt hier in die Innenpolitik
mit Diana Einbürgerungen sollen in
Deutschland künftig schneller und
einfacher möglich sein darauf hat sich
die Ampelkoalition geeinigt künftig
sollen Einwanderer nur noch fünf Jahre
in Deutschland leben müssen bis sie den
deutschen Pass bekommen können vorher
waren es acht auch die doppelte
Staatsangehörigkeit ist laut
Gesetzentwurf möglich Voraussetzungen
für eine Einbürgerung soll unter anderem
ein eigenes Einkommen sein und dass
keine antisemitisch oder rassistisch
motivierten Straftaten begangen wurden
die SPD in Bremen hat nach ihrem
Wahlsieg erste Sondierungsgespräche
geführt am Vormittag traf sich die SPD
um Andreas bovenschulte mit den Grünen
nachmittags mit den Linken bisher
regierte ein Rot-Grün rotes Bündnis das
kleinste Bundesland rechnerisch wäre
dies auch weiterhin möglich auch eine
Koalition von SPD und CDU hätte die
Mehrheit der Sitze morgen sind Gespräche
mit den Christdemokraten geplant
in Iran sind drei weitere
regierungskritische Demonstranten
hingerichtet worden den Männern wurde
vorgeworfen bei den Protesten drei
Sicherheitskräfte getötet zu haben laut
Amnesty International wurden ihre
Geständnisse unter Folter erzwungen die
Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Amtsberg verurteilte die
Hinrichtungen für die Entgrenzung der
Gewalt finde sie kaum noch Worte bereits
Anfang des Jahres waren vier
Protestteilnehmer hingerichtet worden
im Prozess um den Mord am slowakischen
Enthüllungsjournalisten Jan kurze Jack
und seiner Verlobten ist der
Hauptangeklagte freigesprochen worden
laut Gericht konnte dem Unternehmer
Marian Kotsch nah erneut nicht
nachgewiesen werden die Morde in Auftrag
gegeben zu haben seine angebliche
Komplizin und vertraute Alena wurde
dagegen zu 25 Jahren Haft verurteilt
kuciak und seine Verlobte waren im
Februar 2018 erschossen worden zuvor
hatte der investigativ Journalist auch
über die Geschäfte von kotschner
berichtet
in Serbien sind erneut 10000 Menschen
auf die Straße gegangen um gegen Gewalt
zu demonstrieren es ist einer der
größten Proteste der letzten Jahre die
demonstrieren dann forderten den
Rücktritt von Präsident Vucic die
Proteste richten sich auch gegen die
regierungsnahen Medien
auslöser waren zwei tödliche Angriffe
Anfang Mai die nicht unmittelbar in
einem Zusammenhang stehen
zwei Tage nach den heftigen Regenfällen
in Italien ist die Zahl der Toten auf 14
gestiegen um die Stadt Ravenna spitzte
sich die Lage heute weiter zu
Rettungskräfte fvierten Einwohner viele
Menschen wurden aufgefordert ihre Häuser
zu verlassen über 10.000 Menschen leben
derzeit in Notunterkünften heute begann
es wieder zu regnen was weitere
Erdrutsche wahrscheinlicher macht in der
Region geht die höchste
unwetterwarnstufe
selten zuvor hat ein Gesetz zu solchen
Wirbel verursacht noch bevor wirklich
klar ist was genau drin stehen wird und
ab wann es tatsächlich gelten soll das
Gebäude Energiegesetz GEG allgemein
bekannt als harbex heizungsgesetz ist
selbst in der Regierungskoalition
dermaßen umstritten dass die Lage
langsam unübersichtlich wird die FDP
habe dazu noch 100 Fragen heißt es jetzt
in der SPD finden manche dass es zu
einseitig auf die Wärmepumpe setze und
dann gibt es die die in all dem wir wahr
regelmäßig fordern man müsste zügig
Klarheit schaffen Oliver Heuchert
versucht das jetzt mit konkreten Zahlen
und einer Beispielrechnung
der Installateur Stefan Becker reinigt
deine Wärmepumpe auch solche Geräte
sollten einmal im Jahr überprüft werden
Kontakte Ventile Dichtigkeit
die Wärmepumpen stehen in diesen
Doppelhäusern bei Karlsruhe gebaut in
den 90ern Vermieter und Installateur
rüsten auf Wärmepumpen um ohne
zusätzliche Dämmung oder
Fußbodenheizungen bisher haben wir
überhaupt gar keine Probleme ja also ich
bin sehr zufrieden
was ist der Vorteil von Wärmepumpen
Vorteil ist denke ich dass sie
energetisch die effizienteste Lösung
darstellen effizienter geht's meines
Wissens nach mit keiner Heizung die uns
zur Verfügung steht diese Wärmepumpe hat
vor gut einem Jahr noch 43.000 €
gekostet davon kamen 19.000 Euro als
Förderung vom Staat
mittlerweile aber verschickt
heizungsmeister Klaus staut Angebote für
Wärmepumpen ähnlicher Größe die noch mal
deutlich teurer sind
Staud bietet eine Wärmepumpe mit Einbau
für rund 53.000 Euro an für ein
klassisches Einfamilienhaus 130
Quadratmeter 20.000 Kilowattstunden
Jahresverbrauch an fossile Energie der
Staat würde eine Förderung von 24.000
Euro zahlen blieben 29.000 Euro die der
Kunde wirklich zahlen muss viel Geld
eine neue Gasheizung würde 20.000 Euro
kosten deutlich weniger die
Anschaffungspreise sind ziemlich hoch
weil alles gerät an für sich schon als
einzelnes Gerät schon 18 20.000 Euro
kostet plus das Drumherum und bis es ein
und ausgebautes Elektroanschluss ist
halt einfach so teuer ohne Förderung
fast nicht zu verkaufen also es ohne
eine Förderung ist das nicht zu
verkaufen der Installateur wartet
allerdings dass die Preise demnächst
wieder sinken und er weiß auf einen
finanziellen Vorteil der Wärmepumpe hin
denn im laufenden Betrieb ist die
günstiger als fossil betriebene
Heizungen
eine Modellrechnung in einem typischen
Einfamilienhaus verbraucht eine Heizung
mit fossiler Energie rund 20.000
Kilowattstunden im Jahr die Wärmepumpe
aus dem Angebot wird mit einem Verbrauch
von 4.300 Kilowattstunden gerechnet
ermittelt mit den aktuellen Preisen der
Energiepreis bremsen und den co2-abgaben
liegen die Gesamtkosten also
Anschaffungs- und Betriebskosten
zusammen nach 10 Jahren bei ungefähr
45.000 € in etwa gleich auf
das liegt daran dass eine Wärmepumpe aus
einer Kilowattstunde Strom drei bis vier
Kilowattstunden Wärme bereitstellen kann
während immer wenn wir Verbrennungen im
Spiel haben dann gibt es immer Verluste
das heißt eine Kilowattstunde Gas wird
nie in Form von Wärme hinterher da sein
sondern bei der Verbrennung und der
Verteilung im Haus gibt es Verluste und
das ist der große Vorteil der Wärmepumpe
die Wartung der Wärmepumpe bei Karlsruhe
hat keine Mängel zu Tage gefördert bei
einer Wärmepumpe ist sie etwas billiger
als bei fossilen Heizungen man braucht
keinen Schornsteinfeger
so wir haben das an dieser Stelle schon
häufiger thematisiert diese merkwürdige
Diskrepanz zwischen der Stimmung die die
Wirtschaft nach außen verbreitet und den
Rekorden am Aktienmarkt
trotz Krieg und Krisen Konjunktursorgen
und hoher Inflation ist der DAX in den
vergangenen Monaten immer weiter
gestiegen und heute dann sogar auf ein
neues Rekord hochgeklettert dieser
Höhenflug Sina meinet hat vor allem
etwas mit der Hoffnung auf eine baldige
Einigung im US-Schuldenstreit zu tun
dabei gibt es da jetzt am Abend eher
negative Signale oder in der Tat so
haben die Republikaner nämlich am Abend
überraschend die Gespräche pausiert so
dass wieder fraglich ist ob dieser
Drohne Zahlungsausfall der größten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt noch
rechtzeitig abgewendet werden kann der
DAX stand heute in der Spitze bei
16.32 Punkten und damit auf einen neuen
Allzeithoch weil es eben nach dieser
herbei gesehnten Einigung im
US-Schuldenstreit ausgesehen hat nach
dem Rückschlag bei den Verhandlungen hat
dann aber auch das Börsenbarometer
wieder den Rückwärtsgang eingelegt ein
politisches Kräftemessen jenseits des
Atlantiks was zu einer Lösung führen
sollte denn sonst könnte das
Finanzsystem weltweit aus den Fugen
geraten
gab es aber auch noch positive
Nachrichten und zwar aus der deutschen
Wirtschaft richtig denn der Anstieg der
Erzeugerpreise für gewerbliche Produkte
hat sich weiter verlangsamt
Erzeugerpreise bilden die Preise ab die
der Hersteller für seine Produkte
verlangt und bei ihnen ist es mit 4,1
Prozent im April verglichen zum
Vorjahreswert das geringste plus seit
zwei Jahren es darf aber eben nicht
darüber hinweg täuschen dass die Preise
damit immer noch steigen die
Erzeugerpreise sind Vorboten sie deuten
auch darauf hin wie sich letztendlich
die Verbraucherpreise entwickeln und bis
die Verbraucher aber diese leichte
Abschwächung des Preisanstiegs bei
Vorprodukten spüren dürfte es noch ein
Weilchen dauern vielen Dank Sina nach
Frankfurt
der SV Darmstadt 98 ist zurück in der
Fußball-Bundesliga durch den 1 zu 0
Heimerfolg gegen den ersten fC Magdeburg
ist den Lilien bereits am vorletzten
Spieltag der Aufstieg nicht mehr zu
nehmen
zur Eishockey WM in Finnland einen Tag
nach dem Sieg gegen Dänemark setzte sich
die deutsche Eishockey-Mannschaft auch
gegen Österreich mit vier zu zwei durch
erfolgreichster Spieler war Nico Sturm
der zwei Tore zum Sieg bei steuerte
damit hält sich das Team von
Bundestrainer Harald Kreis den Einzug
ins Viertelfinale offen am Sonntag geht
es mit einem Spiel gegen Ungarn weiter
am Dienstag wartet Frankreich
etwas mehr als die Hälfte der größten
Seen weltweit verzeichnet zum Teil
erhebliche Wasserverluste das ist das
Ergebnis einer neuen Studie für die rund
250.000 Satellitenaufnahmen aus fast 30
Jahren ausgewertet wurden als
Hauptgründe für die Austrocknung nennen
die Wissenschaftler den Klimawandel und
einen übermäßigen Wasserverbrauch durch
den Menschen
so und jetzt gucken wir nach oben ins
All wer früher hoch hinaus wollte in den
Weltraum war angewiesen auf die
staatlichen raumfahrtbehörden heute ist
die NASA selbst angewiesen auf private
Konkurrenz sie ist in vielen Fällen nur
noch Kunden zum Beispiel bei einem der
auch mit Elektroautos auf der Erde den
Markt aufmischt und mit erotischen
Entscheidungen ein Social Media Imperium
schaffen will Susanne Freitag über die
neue Wirklichkeit im Universum
ganz normaler Abend am Strand von Kate
in Florida
Familienausflug zum Raketenstart
hier werden gerade 55 neue
starlingssatelliten in den Orbit
geschossen mit einer Falken neuen Rakete
von SpaceX dem Unternehmen von ihnen
Maske
das macht der Eimer die Woche wie ein
Bus immer pünktlich die Raketentechnik
ist nicht so kompliziert wie bei den
Großen mondraketen aber sie sind
effizient und machen den Job
allein im letzten Jahr schickte Elon
Musk 61 Raketen in den Orbit als er das
Unternehmen vor 21 Jahren gründete war
Hans königsmann sein Mitarbeitern Nummer
4 20 Jahre lang war er bei SpaceX
Chefingenieur für Raketenstarts vor
allen Dingen hat SpaceX Alter erkannt
was die Raumfahrt das ist halt die
Tatsache dass man die Rakete jedes Mal
wegschmeißt und okay das groß und was
groß ist halt teuer
Raketen die wiederverwertbar sind eine
Revolution in der Branche das heißt die
Raumfahrt wird billiger und und das halt
in der Zeit alles teurer wird ein
Beispiel dafür die europäische Rakete
Ariane 6 ihr Staat verzögert sich seit
drei Jahren die Kosten stiegen auf vier
Milliarden Euro wiederverwertbar ist sie
nicht Astronauten kann sie auch nicht
transportieren das soll sich ändern
beschloss die europäische
Raumfahrtagentur Isa in diesem Jahr denn
SpaceX ist dabei Europa abzuhängen
wir haben eine ganz neue Situation durch
einen Wettbewerber der die Welt
beherrscht um das mal klar zu sagen wenn
Europa beim Zugang zum
al-konkurrenzfähig sein will müssen wir
uns auch verändern
die artemis-mondrakete von NASA und ESA
flog im November erstmals Richtung Mond
einer Volk aber teuer die nächste Rakete
muss neu gebaut werden
bei Flügen zur Internationalen
Raumstation ISS aber ist ihnen Musk ein
unverzichtbarer Partner geworden die
Astronauten von Isa und NASA nutzen die
wiederverwertbaren SpaceX Raketen sie
sind unschlagbar günstig
also zum einen sind die Agenturen
oftmals unter bestimmten politischen
Zwängen ja die sich selber teilweise
auch erledigen auferlegen nicht und die
private Industrie hat halt eben nicht
diese diese diese Einschränkung
das war der Jungfernflug von Starship
ihnen Rakete
[Applaus]
der Staat scheiterte nach wenigen
Minuten er wurde trotzdem als Erfolg
gefeiert viel testen bringt viel
Erkenntnis für die Raketen der Zukunft
wiederverwertbar natürlich damit wollen
sie Mond und Mars erkunden und einen
Milliarden Markt erobern
und auf der Erde sieht die Zukunft
zunächst mal nach heute show aus und
dann gibt es für sie gegen
Null uns das heute schon mal Update und
zwar mit Christopher Wehrmann und morgen
freuen wir beide uns wieder auf sie bis
dahin vom gesamten Team ein angenehmen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend jetzt am Wochenende wird
es richtig warm der temperaturtrend für
Magdeburg zeigt uns am Sonntag und am
Montag bis 27 Grad Mitte der nächsten
Woche dann gehen die Werte wieder auf um
20 Grad zurück wir blicken jetzt
zunächst noch einmal nach Italien denn
der Tiefe Luftdruck über dem Mittelmeer
sorgt für weitere Regenfällen in den
Hochwassergebieten Italiens vor allem
kommen jetzt noch mal heftige
Regenmassen im Piemont und auch auf
Korsika und Sardinien herunter dann
blicken wir zu uns da bringt uns nämlich
eine östliche Strömung hier am Rande
dieses hochdruckgebietes diese wärmere
und auch feuchtere Luft und die
Warmluftzufuhr sorgt dafür dass ich
heute Nacht Wolken nordwestlich
ausbreiten einzelne Schauer kannst da
mal geben wo es aufklärt sinken die
Werte auf 5 Grad ansonsten ist Frost
jetzt nachts kein Thema mehr im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet z.B bleibt es bei 11
Grad morgen wird es frühlingshaft 16
Grad im deutschen Bergland 23 Grad in
den südöstlichen Landesteilen nur an den
Küsten ist es mit 15 16 Grad kühler
besonders hier spürt man auch den bööch
auffrischenden nordöstlichen Wind dazu
gibt es viele Wolken gelegentlich mal
Sonne am meisten sieht man die im
Nordwesten und im Südosten im östlichen
Bergland und an den Alpen sind
vormittags auch erste Schauer drin
nachmittags sind hier dann einzelne
Gewitter mit Starkregen möglich und
diese Schauer und auch die
Unwettergefahr die nimmt dann bis zum
Montag zu und dann sind eben auch
Unwetter möglich bei dieser
frühsommerlichen Luftmasse mit bis 29
Grad